you were born in South Korea yes what
age did you move that could mean nothing
yeah doesn't necessarily mean they were
also born in South Korea it could mean
absolutely nothing now you you like to
visit there and sort of keep up with
what's going on culturally yeah like in
the world of entertainment in South
Korea so tell us your like our cultural
reporter what's happening there I
actually went back and I did this Funny
or Die video that incorporated this
thing this phenomenon called mukbang
which is people get paid to eat in front
of the camera on the internet like
deliciously and they get paid tons of
money people need to just enjoy the food
enjoy the food yeah and like usually
they're typically like really really
attractive women that are like
seductively eating some ramen or
something but that I understand yeah
yeah that makes that crosses all
cultural barrier but my favorite one is
there's this guy that is basically the
Korean Peter Griffin mm-hm and he goes
nuts on some food and and and there's a
video of that that you brought yes this
is a very popular video in South Korea
of a guy going nuts over his food let's
take a look
[Music]
[Laughter]
how does he sustain that I'm not of joy
I mean it's probably delicious yeah you
got to differentiate yourself if if
there's hot women eating food you got to
do something to up your up your game
your game yeah I don't think I think I
would prefer watching the women eat the
ramen but that was that's the kind of
thing I think we should if we could use
that video on our show yeah if I'm
talking to someone and it's not going
anywhere from now on I'm just gonna cut
to that in a box do that now just and
we'll just cut to it and and suddenly
the whole tone of the interview I love
that guy what's his name do you know
what his name is I Asian Peter Griffin
[Laughter]
you